so I always love asking about the value
of a good scene partner but it feels
especially important here because it's a
two-hander and there are just so many
moments between the two of you where you
say so much without a whole lot of
dialogue so for each of you can you tell
me about a time when the other was just
the same partner you needed and helped
you access something in your own
character that you wouldn't have been
able to reach without them well there's
a scene where I come back to find him
and he doesn't know I'm there and one of
the first lines I say to him is I love
what you've done with your hair and I
don't think there's anyone who I could
have done that not many people I could
have done that with it's a very special
quality of DARS and he elicited that uh
that improv so I I thank you for that
you are a wonderful student partner you
can use my bowl head at any time
yeah no I could have done those scenes
with anyone I don't believe that for a
second no no in all honesty I mean what
can I tell you it's it's it's he is he
is one of our generation's best actors
yeah yeah yeah yeah he is so and you
know in the hands of of guy Richie he
was just
um uh it made it possible and easier for
us to thank God for God because we would
have been at each other's throats
without a guy would have been a comedy
you know not a funny comedy but we would
have made a song I'll watch you guys do
a buddy comedy next I think that's a
good idea yeah in Danish let's give her
some answers okay sorry yes all right
bringing up guy I was uh listening to
another interview you had done Jake
where you were uh talking a little bit
about how he encouraged you guys to not
necessarily memorize your lines but
rather to to work things out on set on
the day together so what would you say
is I guess a new uh tool in your acting
tool kit so to speak that you know came
from having that experience that you're
eager to apply on a future set even if
it isn't run that particular way I mean
you know it wasn't it was about
Discovery in the morning you know we
would write he would write the scenes in
the morning so based on what we had
discovered throughout the process it
would then evolve and change and then he
would add things one of the examples I
could give you is there was an improv
that I said at one point uh where I said
there were a lot of dogs barking at the
end of the scene and I said oh there are
a lot of dogs around here and then he
cut that scene together very quickly
Cuts very quickly uh and he put together
a rough assembly of that scene and that
ended the scene and then he asked for
that line because he remembered it and
he wrote it in a scene much farther
deeper into the movie and it has real
significance as a result so he works
like that you know um it is written and
is written by him but it comes from
discussions in the morning if we have an
idea we bring it to him he yaser Nays it
and we move forward so to me
um it was about agility you know the the
agility to be open to something that
comes to you use your imagination and I
I guess it's really about enjoying
inspiration in a moment and so if it
comes in a scene now oftentimes I'll
bring it up even if it's a it's a no to
a filmmaker I'm working with I think
that part of me is uh is has been
awakened by this process with guy I bet
for you Dar yeah I mean it's also
something that you know but you the
first week was very scary for me because
you know Garrity Jake Gyllenhaal and you
come very prepared as an actor you want
to show what you got and you just have
to throw it all away which is actually
the case in in in all scenes that you
work ever you always have to throw
everything away your preparation but in
this case it was like literally
everything the lines everything and for
me that was scary working in a different
language on a big set but uh you have to
remember that you're in good hands and
you have to just don't use any capacity
to beat yourself up over why you didn't
do it like this or if this line was
wrong it just reminded me of the the the
beauty of the creative process of just
really trusting your abilities and
trusting yourself and being there and
trusting your your partner and uh and
trusting that you know you're working
with a true leader that will you know he
will make the symphony fit at the end
okay get me out of here I will say thank
you for your time congratulations and
the the Buddy comedy next please thank
you so much yeah